before we talk season two um i want to
ask if there's anything you wanted to do
like while you're in l.a well we had a
similar goal yeah we wanted what was
your goal well to eat mexican foods
i
love that this was your goal i actually
i didn't know that that was we knew that
was one of your goals i didn't know if
there were you know plethora but the one
we did know was coming so we wanted to
do something special for y'all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
on the floor if it was not real
i was like they they know me they know
me that's delicious cheers ladies and
gentlemen amazing
on your amazing show now i feel bad like
how'd you ever feel you're not here but
wait wait do you have anything you're
bad
yeah yeah so kelly kelly i was i was
promised there would be mexican coming
to my door
did it come no what have i got in my
fridge
a carrot oh
so justin what are we what all is this
so they know justin's gonna let you know
what everything is yeah well this is
from one of the best known restaurants
in los angeles this is called casa vega
and you guys you guys are actually
having guacamole fresco yeah chili cone
queso
a chicken quesadilla yeah a shrimp
quesadilla quesadilla corn esquitas do
you want me to get the beef taquitos
cone guacamole
chicken taquitos day one big sleeves el
pastor tacos chico's i want to try this
carne asada tacos chicos
fajitas
chicken enchiladas
beef enchiladas two special oven style
burritos oh my gosh and margaritas
[Applause]
um enjoy you justin and also
i guess we just really wanted to rub
that in some more agility sorry
thank you thank you in detail
i've got a vodka so it's all good so
it's all good your liquid diet i like it
[Music]